hello everyone and a Merry Christmas
everyone uh we have a very nice game
today from the aana tournament of 2001
it was a tournament that was sort of a
celebration of the 10year independence
of Kazakhstan of the from the Soviet
Union and uh this is a game from the
final round of the tournament so it's
kasaro with the white pieces Vladimir
kramnik current world champion Vladimir
kramnik with the black pieces and
kramnik is leading the tournament so
casparo needs a win here with the wi
pieces uh to actually uh win the
tournament kaspar and Kik in 2001 at the
time this game was played were the only
two players rated over
2800 and um uh well this was uh of
course somewhat after their famous World
CH championship match and it's
interesting that um kaspar mentions this
all the time and the reason why I'm
showing you this game is I watched um
the podcast on the C squar podcast with
um faan Coran and Christian Cilla they
had Kasparov as a guest and then uh he
he mentioned this game briefly and I you
know I thought about it and I was like
i' I've never covered this game and it's
really a shame but probably because I
haven't covered their match I'm also
attempting to do not attempting I'm also
at some point um preparing to do that uh
but uh yeah this game is very
interesting because in the actual match
Kasparov couldn't really get any play
with the white pieces the match won by
the match ended by Kasparov not winning
a single game Kik of course became world
champion and the uh the the well
inFAMOUS or the famous Berlin defense
was employed by Vladimir kramnik four
times interestingly five times R Lopez
was on the board but uh out of one of
those five times Kik actually went for
the morphy defense he didn't go for the
Berlin defense I don't know why maybe he
just had a hunch that U Kasparov had
something ready after the first three
games but then he returned to the Berlin
defense in the fifth game and again
Kasparov couldn't really uh get any sort
of a game so this is why this game is so
famous not just because uh of the
situation of the tournament like I said
it's a final round Kik needs uh only
only a draw to to secure the tournament
uh but also because once again Kasparov
will test King's Berlin defense so uh
without further Ado let's check it out
Kasparov has the white pieces and he
opens with Pawn to E4 uh we have Pawn to
E5 by kramnik Knight to F3 we have
Knight to C6 and now Bishop to B5 D
Lopez is on the board and here comes
Knight to F6 the Berlin defense we have
castles and just Knight captures on on
e4 the Rio Gambit accepted it's again
very very standard stuff D4 Knight to D6
and now Bishop captures on C6 much like
you would see in a in a modern game d
captures D captures on E5 uh Knight to
F5 and now Queens get traded off the
board we have captur captures and Knight
to C3 so again uh exactly the same as
you would see it played nowadays we have
Pawn to H6 and pawn to H3 Bishop to D7
uh and pawn to B3 now preparing to fian
to the uh the dark Square Bishop uh and
now King to E8 this is sort of a a
difference between today's games
nowadays uh we know from our good friend
the engines that King to C8 is the the
preferred move but King T8 is still fine
you can play it but maybe white gets a
bit more out of the game we have Bishop
to B2 by Kasparov uh Rook to d8 and now
Rook 8 to D1 and here comes Knight to E7
and now if you look at KAS far's um
pieces let's say the Rooks on D1 and on
E1 the Knight on F3 and C3 the bishop
already assuming this diagonal uh it
does seem like white is playing a
principal chess whereas black still has
a king in the center everything is you
know piled up here you know it's very
hard to say how this Rook is ever going
to enter the game probably the idea is
to trade as much as possible and then at
some point you know move the king and
get the Rook into the game maybe on move
65 I don't know uh but okay knce to G6
uh has to figure out how to complete
development and now Knight to E4 and
here already a very interesting move
nowadays Bishop to C8 is known uh to be
the the the move here and then of course
you just like I said try and get this
Rook into the game somehow uh but here
Knight to F4 was played by U by Vladimir
and now kasparov's position is actually
already completely winning as of move 15
so it's a very interesting uh setup feel
free to pause the video and try to find
the absolute best move for uh for
Gotti uh while I give you a couple of
seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on always
favoring activity over material and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is Pawn to E6 that's the move
and it looks like a crazy move to even
try because the E6 square is guarded
three times by Black's pieces but the
problem is uh however you recapture
isn't really working if you play Bishop
captures on E6 and then comes Knight to
F6 with check and now look at this G
captures Bishop captures on F6
threatening checkmate with Rook captures
on8 so of course you will trade once but
once white r captures again mate is
being threatened so you have to figure
out a way of stopping that let's say
Bishop D5 and then of course white grabs
The Rook on h8 and white is just up
material both players have six pawns but
white is up the exchange so that's the
problem with Bishop captures on E6 if
you play F captures on E6 okay you will
not get checkmated But Here Comes Bishop
to E5 with an attack on C7 and the
Knight on F4 H also one of the reasons
why Knight to F4 does not belong here in
this particular line Knight to G6 let's
say Bishop captures on C7 Rook to C8 and
now Bishop to D6 and it's just a much
better position for white and by much
better I mean winning let's say you you
try to bring the Rook back already you
just trade here captures captures and
now Knight to D6 with check King E7 you
capture on B7 also you can see that it's
it's good that white already has a Pawn
on B3 so you can just move the Knight
you don't have to worry about losing the
B2 Pawn let's say Knight to C5 and now
if let's say Rook F to d8 defending the
bishop here uh you can already end the
game Rook captures on D7 removing the
defender of the E6 Pawn Rook captures
and now Rook captures on E6 with the
Rook hanging with the Knight hanging
this is resigns for black so after E6
you can't really capture with the bishop
you can't capture with the pawn only
things left uh will capture with the
Knight so Knight captures an E6 uh and
here Kasparov played Knight to D4 again
uh Bishop to E5 like in the line that we
just discussed does appear to be more
potent but uh it's uh uh well it's it's
a very tricky position and also uh shows
that Kasparov didn't really have this
prepared at at home he found everything
over the board uh he played Knight to D4
and this allows for a uh for a sneaky
defense with Rook to G8 and Rook to H7
it's crucial to get the Rook off of the
h8 square uh but Kik goes Pawn to C5
instead he challenges the Knight but now
the Knight comes to F5 and here you have
huge problems how do you how do you
tackle this well KY did play Rook to H7
now uh and he probably thought that he
didn't have to play a move prior to this
he he can play Pawn to C5 and then only
as a reaction toight to F5 play Rook to
H7 but it doesn't work for for one key
move that kaspar has here uh feel free
to pause the video and again play the
absolute best move while I give you a
couple of seconds it's Christmas so you
know we could we could throw in a few
more pause the video uh
moments so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on
spotting this wild idea and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it
is Bishop to F6 look at this we can even
do it in slow motion Bishop to F6 and
now you're wondering what is this
madness well uh if G captures on F6
Knight captures on F6 is Checkmate the
Knight on F5 covers D7 square and that's
only one of the issues of having your
King on E8 on move 19 with uh well five
of kasparov's pieces in front of that
King so here cring just moved the Rook
Rook to C8 and now uh okay the most
precise would be Pawn to F4 but Kasparov
goes for a practical Choice he plays
bishop captus and G7 Bishop captus we
have Knight captus and G7 and now rook
capis and G7 Knight to F6 with check
nicely connecting with the bishop on D7
King to E7 and now Knight captures on D7
but it doesn't seem like it's that uh
clean KY just plays Rook to d8 attacks
the Knight Knight to E5 and he trades
off a pair of Rooks captures captures
and just goes Knight back to F4 the the
move that almost uh cost him uh the game
very early on he now repeats it and um
well what uh what do you do here uh it's
a very again a very tricky position
kasar plays King to H1 beautiful move it
seems like you could capture on G2 but
you really can because if you capture
with the Knight then just Rook G1 you
blunder the Knight and if you capture
with the Rook it's not much better if
Rook captures here then Knight to D3
again attacks the Knight defends the F2
Pawn you cannot move the The Rook
otherwise you lose the Knight you cannot
move the Rook to defend the Knight the
pawn covers the the G4 Square so uh the
pawn is actually uh poisoned uh we have
Rook to G5 going after the Knight and
now casparro goes Knight to G4 uh Rook
to D5 offering a rook trade and now Rook
to E1 with check King back to f8 and now
Knight captures on H6 so okay kaspar
wins a pawn but uh is it really is it
really enough well it is if uh kamnik
allows himself to sort of make one more
imprecise move and that is after Rook to
D2 Kasparov played Rook to E5 and the
position can still uh you know uh be
defended but uh you have to you have to
uh you know decide correctly here uh
which Pawn do you capture do you capture
the F2 Pawn or the C2 pawn it seems like
a silly question but it might not be as
silly as you think so for the last and
third time feel free to pause the video
and tell me which Pawn you grab here and
yes you you do have to grab a
pawn uh so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on being
the the proper Pawn Grabber and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is Rook captures on C2 that's
the pawn you have to capture and the
reason for that is I will show you uh
Caspar's move is of course Rook to F5
with a double attack on the Knight and
on the F7 Pawn so now after Rook to F5
is played now you capture the F2 Pawn
with the Knight being defended and now
if Rook captures an F7 uh you will
simply move King to E8 and now it's uh
it's a game you can play it let's say
Pawn to H4 Pawn to B5 Pawn to G G4 uh
Pawn to A5 white is pushing on the king
side black is pushing on the queen Side
Pawn to G5 let's say Rook to F1 check
King H2 Rook F3 uh keeping the the white
king at Bay uh and now finally if Rook
captures on C7 you will play Rook captur
Rook H3 check and capture on H4 let's
say King to G1 Rook captures on H4 Rook
captures on C5 and now everything just
gets traded off Knight to H3 with check
and after King to G2 you will capture
here Knight captures Rook captures Rook
captures and it's equal material this is
a a dead draw with of course with play
still being only on the queen side uh so
the move is Rook captures on C2 however
cronic played Rook captures on F2 first
and now it's completely different Rook
to F5 was played and now you can't just
continue grabbing Rook captures or Rook
captures the Knight here would be
hanging so it's a huge difference uh but
it doesn't seem like something Kik would
miss so let's see what happened here he
played King to G7 he attacked kasparov's
knight uh what do you play here uh not
of course not Knight captures on F7
because then there's the sneaky Knight
captures on H3 uh offering a trade with
the Knight defending the Rook on F2 so
here kaspar brings the Knight back
Knight to G4 attacks The Rook here uh
and now the problem is you cannot keep
defending the Knight this is what cik
Miss if Rook to F1 with check King H2 uh
what do you play whatever you play
doesn't really matter like Pawn to B5 G3
and that's it you you lose material so
instead Rook captures on G2 was played
Kik will grab the two pawns uh for for
the for the piece uh Rook captures on F4
Rook captures on C2 and now Rook uh to
F2 offering a rook trade and defending
the pawn on A2 Rook to C3 but now just
King to G2 yes K does have two pawns but
a knight is a knight uh you know some
someone said a Fisher is a Fisher is
Fisher but a knight is a knight uh Pawn
to B5 we have Pawn to H4 Pawn to C4 now
cik will create a pass Pawn here and of
course still try to uh to play this Pawn
to H5 we have C captures and B3 a
captures and now Rook to C5 going after
the H Pawn if you can eliminate the H
Pawn then you are you are getting closer
to a draw but of course Pawn to H6 with
check King to f8 and now Knight to F6 we
have Rook to G5 with check and here
kaspar just played King to H1 and he was
in this position on move 41 that
Wladimir Kik resigned the game rather
world champion Vladimir Kik resigned the
game as there is nothing more to be done
here so Kasparov finally breaks through
the uh Berlin def defense he he shatters
the Berlin Wall something that he could
not do over the course of four games
during their 2000 World CH championship
match uh he does it now he gets his
revenge in the final round and wins the
tournament and I think uh going into
this tournament kaspar was like um maybe
even on on a nine Tournament winning
streak like he won nine tournaments in a
row or maybe this was his ninth
tournament uh win in a row but still I
mean a absolute mad Ness uh and yeah he
takes down world champion Vladimir Kik
and gets Soul first place in
this aana Tournament of 2001 uh so yeah
uh great stuff here and the reason why
you resign of course is uh well the king
cannot uh get near that H Pawn and if
try something like Rook G3 you want to
go after the pawn uh look at how elegant
this is Pawn to H7 let's say Rook H3
check you're going to block Rook H2 and
now after captures captures King G7
stops the queening of the pawn but now
look at this Pawn to B4 the move that
always wins also wins here you stop A5
you stop C5 uh King captures on F6 is
impossible due to h8 Queen and for those
of you who really love it when I finish
the game and I will as it's Christmas uh
let's say A5 captures and now B4 you
start pushing for the queen and both
players get a queen into the game uh A8
Queen let's say B1 Queen but now the h8
square is defended so he'll just bring
bring a Queen into the game and you can
finish this however you want your you
know your your uncle could easily win
this with White Queen to H5 with check
you're going to capture here uh Queen to
d8 with check and after King to G7 uh
let's say just you know Queen D to h8
will deliver Checkmate so of course Kik
did not allow any of this to happen on
the board he realized what is going on
and uh well he he he played it I believe
up until time control as the resignation
was made on move 41 but after that it
really uh
you know there was no point in
continuing the game uh so yeah that's
the game hope you guys enjoyed it very
nicely very nicely done by Kasparov
finally taking down the the Berlin
defense uh I mean after Kik took down
Kasparov in their 2000 World CH
championship match um uh the the Berlin
defense really got uh really got popular
and you know everyone's been playing it
ever since even today it's extremely
popular uh but Kasparov showed that you
know it's not it's not bulletproof if
you if you know uh find a tactical idea
like that pawn to E6 movie it was really
an outstanding uh resource uh so yeah
once again really hope you guys enjoyed
it I would like to thank Yun Jack
schroer Seria Isaac Davis and Timothy
rosan for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you all for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World so thank you all I will
see you soon and once again a Merry
Christmas everyone